hey it's been dope to see uh just your
come up dude I've been um you know I use
your layout cuz I always talk to
aspiring singers and songwriters right
and I always use you as an example to
like how to use the internet in your
favor cuz if you're super talented like
you have the voice of an Angel right
well thank you I found you I think it
was I think it was the Mario cover all
right yeah like 2019 yeah yeah and um
ever since then I subscribed to the
YouTube channel and I always will show
people like yo there's this guy Teddy
swims like he's doing like covers but
he's doing them like with like care with
like high production value and like you
know it it's dope that you know that was
kind of like would you say that those
covers were kind of your way in to kind
of becoming discovered on a big
absolutely man I we really really
originally didn't intend on doing them
was just like so June 25th of 2019 was
the first one we did and I wanted to
just kind of pay homage to Michael
Jackson cuz it was 10 years after he
died and we just woke up and it was just
kind of going crazy so we were like I
mean I think I think the first year that
first day after we posted it we woke up
with like 10,000 views you know and and
now that such like seems like such a
middle school number if I get like not
if I don't get a million on something
now I'm like oh [__] kill me I suck you
know but but that 10,000 we woke up to
bro and we were like holy [__] guys we
got
10,000 views what the [__] you know and
it it was it was so cool man and uh and
so since then we like I guess this is
working we we just kept going and kept
doing more covers and and started you
know and that's kind of what Teddy swims
just kind of became its own thing
because um we were we were banned
forever you know and then it was just
that that just kind of went off and
we're just I guess we're just shifting
gears and me and all my buds and you
know just just kept doing it at what
point in time were you like cuz I know
there had to be a point in time where
every major label was coming at you like
like almost like you're LeBron James
like a free agent it it was quite it was
quite neat too cuz uh so I I once once
those like covers started really kind of
going off and and that that Mario cover
was really one that was first starting
to go and uh and Shai Twain Still The
One cover really did a lot for us and
but after that first one I was talking
to my buddies at the time and cuz we
were all in bands and stuff I was still
in a metal band and and still playing
and uh and I and we we would have like
the same guys that would you know kind
of record us man my good friendly Rous
and and uh My Buddy Aaron and Joel who
like filmed filmed the videos and so at
one point we were just kind of he did a
great job yeah we had we had we had I
got had this idea was like look man I
think I think if we I think we just all
put our heads together like let's just
like just do this do covers like weekly
let's just get together write songs for
this project that way when we get ready
to you know get signed or whatever it is
that we're going to do I just asked my
friends to give me like 6 months of
their time and I said just 6 months and
we're man so we all moved into this
house together and nville Georgia and it
was like a five-bedroom house and we
like put plyboard walls up and made two
bedrooms out I mean we ended up making
this thing like a nine-bedroom house it
five but it was really nine yeah it was
like nine bedroom house man we had like
15 I think 12 of us were living there
and like 15 of us were there every day
it was a [__] and this is where you
guys were recording yeah it was like
[__] tavaa over there man you know
what I'm saying and we we so we we had
like we had built like two studios in it
and then you know we had our like we had
our uh our garage was was where we like
could the dist our own merch too and my
brother would come over there and
distribute our merch and it was the
merch Factory in the garage yes like do
two studios in there a bunch of rooms
and I just figured like I was like well
we can film we can record we can write
we can sing we can make all this stuff
ourselves we can we can do all of it we
can take the pictures we can distribute
the merch so I like it just 6 months
let's all put our heads together on this
and if it if it works out then like
we're all going to be straight because
we we don't need anybody you know and um
sure enough we June 25th of 2019 was the
first cover we did and in December 24th
of 2019 uh I signed a Warner Records and
put all my best buds on salary it was a
day less than 6 months which is [__]
wild out like just speaking things into
existence and you put all the homies who
were there with you on the team all your
[__] they're still they're still [__]
same van and still same guys and and now
we're actually making pretty damn good
money man so beauti thing everybody's
everybody's doing good and uh aot lots
of them about to move out here too man
and just keep and they've all had like
right and cut on records with me and
producing cuts and you know we just we
keep we keep going together man no it's
been dope to see man um so you say you
were in a metal band around the time you
did the first cover yeah sure was man I
was I was in my whole life I spent a lot
of those uh you can still find some of
the stuff it's called Uh this band's
called AIS a e r i s and you can find it
what kind of metal are we talking here
it was like it was like kind of a more
post metal core kind of those singing
there some Screaming a little more some
some kind of active Rock situation
little hardore little metal core kind of
little bit of everything in it you know
just it it it was all right it was
pretty good there's some there's some
decency in it yeah so all that stuff's
still out there for everybody yeah sure
is man